wrap up dogs and burgers and have them
the next day they will never ever come
close to what they should try to eat
white meat turkey the next day it's
drier than wood I put it in the
microwave gravy all right I put it in
the microwave with a little ketchup or
mustard I mean what are we talking about
here anything can moisten up meat the
way that Thanksgiving leftovers are
something that people talk about in and
look forward to I never hear that
equivalent to barbecue leftovers tell me
you're going to eat a kebab there's a
reason two days later there's a reason
Kebab in two days there's a reason the
kebabing on July 6th there's a kebab all
July you won't Kabob you have no idea
not with leftover Kebab Thanksgiving
dinner is a gigantic pain in the ass you
don't understand you live on this puffy
Cloud way up in famous person land we're
all not living on that cloud you come in
you talking about this is the way he
does taste buds is the way he is in real
life yeah it's it's brutal it's every
time with everything